hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer question from
one of our readers Anastasia who's a
comedian and wrote in asking for my
advice so she wrote hello Evan love
receiving your emails and instant on
business however i was wondering on
device you can give to someone who's
their own product I'm a stand-up
comedian and I am remarkable I need to
know how to get into corporate America
please go to my website and give me your
honest opinion on my image given a
better one or anything else that can
improve on I sincerely Revere your
opinion so please be honest and there's
link to her website so Anastasia I can
relate I am my own product too we may
serve different markets I'm not very
funny but what I do i do really well as
well so let's load up your site and see
what we can talk about so here's the
website when I look at it I don't really
see something that is geared towards
corporate America it seems more of a
consumer play so you have these
different events that are popping up
here promoting where you're going to be
doing your next gig which is great but
there's nothing here that talks about
corporate America so as I scroll down
you know bold black leadership rally
rising the cop comedy show I don't get
the sense that you're committing who
targets corporate America so I would try
to revamp this page a little bit maybe
start by changing your value proposition
here so you know instead of diva of
comedy maybe something about how you
helped corporate America if you have
your picture here maybe a quick bio and
you're here to say how you helped
different corporations why they should
hire you because again if I looked at
this if I was working on a big company I
wouldn't think that you're the type of
comedian who would work for my show
whatever i'm putting on so it does look
more like a consumer-oriented brand the
next thing I would do is also have
testimonials so I don't know if you've
done it in corporate gigs ietter if
you're working on getting your first
ones but as soon as you do have them
write in a testimonial have them put
something on there that says you know
Anastasia was the life of the conference
or you know whatever it is that you're
going to be doing have somebody on there
hopefully you can show their face but
worst case just a testimonial what
company they're from that would be
fantastic and that gives me some
confidence in that you're able to
deliver a message for these type of
corporate events looking through your
your sub header here there's some things
that you might want to consider updating
starting here at the end this register
member directory I don't really know
what what it means it's kind of
confusing so connect to the community
with your existing account I didn't know
there was an estate into the bold
community so you might want to remove
that the member directory is empty so
again I would just take that off it
doesn't really add anything to your side
and just confuses people who are
clicking through your blog is a little
bit outdated and there's only one post
so talking about relationships and sex
great but you know a couple months old
you may want to in here again start
posting about some of the corporate work
you're doing or how you can potentially
help corporations so if I am from a big
corporation to come line on your site
and click on your blog I can see that
you're the type of person that I want to
hire the next thing we do is looking at
your video clips let's wait for it to
load up here there's only one clip that
loads for me here and first of all I
would put a video on the homepage and it
could be a welcome video asking people
to you know go and check out your site
or clips of you talking and doing your
thing one video is probably not going to
be enough so I definitely try to mix it
up and put some more videos on here the
topic is also about religion so as a
Christian video which is great for some
people but might turn a lot of people
off so if you do other calm body as well
then you might want to put other
examples in here so that your
multi-dimensional if that's if that's
what you do then that's fine that just
also maybe show more examples especially
if you've done corporate gigs you then
you can record those you want to put
them up here and I'd start putting them
out on youtube as well you know put more
out any time you can do do these little
recordings when I do these videos now it
helps us app
me as an expert for entrepreneurship and
people subscribe to the channel and I
get interest in it so you know the more
videos you put up on YouTube and the
more you funny they are and people want
to check them out and subscribe to your
channel the more likely you're going to
be able to track the corporate audience
as well so definitely try to put some
more of your stuff up on YouTube and
maybe even do a weekly comedy you know
quick thing five minutes you know you
and your house or you know whatever the
studio filming joke of the week
something to start building an audience
the last thing I want to talk about for
your site was if i click on booking
request it doesn't work so you know if
you want people to write in and book you
for different gigs you have to have a
book request page that works i'm sure
that's it that's a quick and easy fix
but I definitely try to check that out
so up with a few ideas in the other that
can help you Anastasia I thought I'd
might also quickly show you what I do on
my side because I do a lot of corporate
work I'm not a comedian but I do a lot
of corporate work so this is my page it
talks about me and the first thing I do
is I showcase all the different media
coverage that I've done so I've been in
the New York Times am Asheville Wall
Street Journal I've been on TV done a
lot of different interviews and for the
people who hire me who are corporations
they want to see that I'm an expert I
know what I'm talking about so I want to
create a patriot that shows that I know
what I'm talking about so for you
corporations want to come and see that
you've worked with other brands and that
you know what you're doing and they'll
want to see different video clips and
different pictures of you or different
events to make it a little bit easier
for them to want to come and contact you
so I definitely try to put some of that
stuff up i don't know if you've been in
the media at all but that stuff it
definitely helps if you haven't been in
the media then again just pictures from
different events in different video
clips the next thing I do is I have a
paragraph that talks about the different
brands that I work with so these are
corporate clients of mine that I've
worked with and you know again if I'm a
new corporation that I'm interested in
potentially working with Evan Carmichael
I'll see all these you know name brand
companies that he's worked with and so
it gives me more confidence that he's
going to be able to help me so again if
you've worked with
Oprah clients put their logos up try to
get testimonials that I really help you
and then the video so i have a video
that talks about me it's me saying hey
I'm having kind of like a welcome to my
site I talk a little bit about myself my
story background etc and it gets people
to know a little bit more about me so
having a welcome video definitely helps
and then below I have a whole bunch of
you know text introducing myself ongoing
signature video you know official bio
more pictures and then quotes you know
here are some that I've done
presentations different speaking
engagements and here's an example of a
testimonial somebody left for me so this
page really works it converts well it
targets the corporate market and I've
been able to get a lot of gigs from it
so for you I definitely try to
incorporate some of those elements and
hopefully that'll help you get some of
those corporate jobs and help you grow
your business and take it to that next
step so when I say gee I hope you found
the video useful everybody else as well
if you guys liked the video please give
it a thumbs up below and I'd also love
to hear thoughts and feedback if you
want to leave a comment under the video
and stay tuned for the next episode
you